mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
suppose abcd is a square
suppose point e is in the interior such
that angle edc is equal to 15 degrees
and angle ecd is also equal to 15
degrees
construct eb
the question is to solve for the measure
of angle ebc
i thank totally for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
i will present two ways to solve the
problem the first uses geometry and the
second uses trigonometry
let's get started with the geometry
solution
we will first consider a triangle edc
we will construct a congruent triangle
alongside bc
label the point on the interior as f
now since fcb is equal to 15 degrees and
ecd is equal to 15 degrees and angle c
is a right angle which measures 90
degrees
we can conclude that ecf is equal to 60
degrees
next construct f e
by construction c f and c e are
congruent sides
therefore we have an isosceles triangle
with a vertex angle equal to 60 degrees
this means the other two angles will
both be equal to 60 degrees as well
therefore triangle efc is an equilateral
triangle and ef is also equal to ec and
fc
from here we will calculate the measure
of angle bfc
we know that fbc is equal to 15 degrees
so we can calculate the remaining angle
in the triangle is equal to 150 degrees
we then have the three angles around
point f must sum to 360 degrees so we
can calculate that e f b is also equal
to 150 degrees
we then have the triangles fbc
and fbe are congruent by side angle side
thus angle fbe is also equal to 15
degrees
therefore angle ebc is equal to 15
degrees plus 15 degrees which is equal
to 30 degrees and that's the answer
now let's solve the problem using
trigonometry
suppose that f is the midpoint of dc and
g is the midpoint of a b
f g will be the perpendicular bisector
of dc and the perpendicular bisector of
a b
since e is equidistant from the vertices
d and c e will be along f g
without loss of generality suppose the
square has a side length equal to 2.
then fc will be equal to 1 and gb will
also be equal to 1.
from here f e will be equal to the
tangent of 15 degrees which is equal to
the tangent of 30 degrees over 2.
we can then use the tangent half angle
formula tangent of theta over 2 is equal
to the sine of theta divided by the
quantity 1 plus the cosine of theta
we can thus substitute theta is equal to
30 degrees and it's a routine
calculation from here
we merely simplify this fraction
and then we can rationalize it as well
we end up that fe is equal to 2 minus
the square root of 3.
then we can calculate the length of eg
it will be equal to da minus fe
da is equal to 2. we've calculated fe
therefore eg will be equal to the square
root of 3.
from here we will use trigonometry again
consider angle ebg
we know that it's equal to the inverse
tangent of the square root of 3 which is
equal to 60 degrees
then angle b is a right angle therefore
angle ebc must be equal to 30 degrees
and that's our answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems one video at a time
you